here's heremon marquez fifth career
start against the nets yeah marquez's
last start was on the 22nd against the
dodgers he received the no decision in
the rockies 10-5 win two down next up
juan soto who's hit a homer driven in a
couple against irmon marquez
that's a hot shot up the middle 29
months since the nats last played at
coors field and juan soto looks like
he's here every day swinging like that
catch me trey turner
base it up the middle one for one starts
at 322 tied with trade turner right not
anymore not anymore josh bell stands in
one two
bounce towards trevor's story trev will
set fire on to first gets his friend
josh bell for the out
and no damage with the soto single
josiah gray will start for the third
time against colorado yeah 23 years old
6-1 190 last start on the 22nd against
the marlins there you see it right there
six innings six hits two runs brendan
rogers rocky's second baseman
and that hit brendan in the helmet and
he went down he is lying on his back he
is
conscious duggar the rockies head
athletic trainer out there quickly so
scary turned from it and it kind of
caught him below
and just to the backside of his left ear
that caught him right at the bottom of
the batting helmet my guess is garrett
hanson stretching right now on the bench
and he didn't take him out
you got it with with that kind of blow
just with concussions these things gotta
you gotta just make sure and garrett
hampson will come on to replace him so
runner a third two out now and story
will be the batter hitting 245 here's
the pitch swing and a miss struck him
out on the slider in the side retired
bottom half of the third inning josiah
gray facing him on marcus
this is gonna be a tough play shallow
left center and
just builds on that average
that he brought coming in 250. he may
have the final silver slugger for a
pitcher in the national league garrett
hampson's hitting 239
fastball up after the sliders in the
dirt changing some eye levels and hamson
nowhere near reaching that strikeout
number two blackman in from the left
side swinging a ground ball right side
reaching down to backhand at his belt
he'll feed gray covering a little slow
to get there but he speeds up to beat
blackman for the out escobar in his
second opportunity able to come up with
the infield hit soto just hit one as
hard as you can up the middle first time
that's gonna be a called third strike
and one knows it something we see that
doesn't happen very often right there
juan soto just struck out for only the
86th time this year they're loaded with
one out and a huge spot now coming up
for the rookie catcher ruiz
ball four nets lead
ruiz 14th batted in this annette 15th of
the year escobar strolls home garcia
struck out on a slider in the dirt first
time
hit on his hand sharply hit base hit
bell scores yadiel hernandez coming
around
the throw to third gets a runner
ruiz out over there
from charlie blackmon but
the nationals lead three nothing so it's
a two-run single charlie blackman picks
up his 14th outfield assist of the year
gunning down cabret ruiz for the second
out of the inning the nationals make it
a big inning with three runs home
brendon rogers first inning and the
rockies did release the info that he had
passed
the concussion protocols that's great
news after getting hit in the helmet one
out in the last of the fourth
down and in
ruiz dropped it hitter walks away so
strikeout number three for josiah gray
and that gives the rockies a two-out
base runner for elias diaz had a swing
and a miss he struck him out with a
slider so josiah gray gets a couple of
strikeouts in the inning and pitches
around the two-out walk and what a
situation coming up here for juan soto
first and third nobody out
soto on 2-0 hits it hard story's going
to try to turn the double play ball is
dropped so the nats
send thomas home here 93 on the season
too many steps for story there in the
shift couldn't get back to the bag juan
soto just too fast smelling an rbi four
to nothing two out soto at first yadiel
hernandez will be the batter the one two
is hit to the left side diving stop by
hampton gets up throws to first and gets
hernandez
nice play going to his left by garrett
hampson josiah gray who is cruising
along has hit a major bump in the road
here single walk walk krone coming up
who has the rocky season record with
three grand slams
and on a pitch down and in that looked
like ball two
popped up to hernandez
runners will have to stay
yadiel almost all the way home on a fly
one out big out ryan mcmahon next
high drive deep center field way back
and off the wall
two odds has scored the trail runner
story coming home throw to the plate
knock it again
base is clear double by mcmahon here
come the rockies
ryan mcmahon makes it 4-3 washington
it was also close to a grand slam that's
going to end the night for josiah gray
the rockies have men on the corners with
one out hillyard over two
on the pitch up
shallow right
soto calls it
runner coming down the line and stopping
two down and it'll be rio ruiz off the
bench with two outs swinging a towering
pop-up shallow center out goes escobar
the shortstop he's calling with both
hands waving his arms and he makes the
catch
nice work by austin both to come in
and strand the tying run three and two
juan soto has walked 138
times all right 139. long at bet juan
tonight on base for the second time
officially and josh bell swung on and
grounded weakly to second base hampson
has it up with it throws to first to
retire the side two on for rybel toffee
in the eighth fastball hit on the ground
towards short backhanded by escobar jump
throw across to bell in time for the out
and the side retired good play by
escobar to his right he didn't have time
to plant off balance with something on
it to get the out at first base the
nationals have loaded them up and also
escobar will be the batter here
escobar on two strikes
so then ants lead five to three bases
still loaded nobody out this could be an
mvp at bat right here for juan soto and
he'll pop one up
shallow left field coming in tapia right
near the line and he'll fire it in so
that's a big out for carlos estevez to
get soto to pop out next up josh bell
bounce right back to esteban flips it
home for one to first double play
cj crone able to grab it around josh
bell
as elias diaz
had to take a tough throw from estevez
got it and somehow threw it to first for
the out two out bottom of the ninth
inning so now the time run will come up
in cj crowe
crone hard shot down the third base
slide
story picking up stu call he'll get sent
home
he's gonna score easily on the double by
cj
time run at second base with mcmahon
coming up
and now he's the tying run at second
base with two out garcia has it and he
lobs it to bell to end the game and a
curly w is in the books